[Music]
in the private video who 16 hall atomic
martis measure well watch to be on
ethan i mast in the chair
de volta can not count here what i saw
who have the chance at tam i took ball
can u de find it won  it's funny just simply
the number of protons pleasant in fact
nucleus of an atom
well because they want lines go now it will
now become the thomas copy yes simply
means a mass of item is they keep
this moment in much and who have
babouches made  up of xvi not in me
t so fat that it is war so still her
and imas of its own
well who has pictures bike with some stuff and
site this belly is placed on also
whose time then can that time the
death marches to job
bobby de  stam on the mesh of all the
object in side did
absolutly stimuli the masts vanadium and
week own we left the skin of the city
atomic particles in the
what we know that a mano to step dan
i had particles
electronic necklace je bemas that
's the japanese  do to be almost week lesson
so becomes a  l who watches who you we her boat
proton to hjoed because in the news
of that study rushed me mind mars is
what we know that anyone t must indicate your man
services particles area
manufacturers the oil the mass flow tons
of oil the new pride  on bot to get a
since the boot gave significant amount
of mesh who will aunt de the mesh of
breasts guetta
hence the atomic mass is defined testing
total number of percent to new trance
percent able the nucleus of the art'
him
it's older fortwo  is a must namba
the stick the stamping shampoo and choose
that the temple elements looks like florien who
catches that there is a night rattan cents and not
because in the nucleus who is that child
who you ever with color gloss cases with
that you did not have on yes  an economist
foliage plant and new trance
so they had that the number of nu twins
is beautiful
oh timmy dat the presence of this minute
because you plates that had him so the
charge of the had him in queens of the
queen's
goes the lutina that  the cabinet den Nieuwboer
and what you an extra not of boats grass
sultan him back to the atomic mass of
glory who hates mind blown tent a
new trance that was not the blind spot that
was my team suggests i stayed at the
atomic mass of flooring it  nineteen
unit that flight
just like flo new aluminum had an
ex renewed montcalm outside the number
of projects
that is in a single let him or
aluminum who ever has a great land
and fotini for then in on the to be kept
where not have unit pits that
catholic mars or aluminum then the
ladder to the mix temple or chloe up
louis had
it seventeen shows a new fund
that is not diatonic moss or glory of the
core i5 units
white absolutly what width is kind
of use jorien items that i so in nature
extra budget you will find van Staal of den
haag star team rattan tent when you give
trance
it like the atomic mass of glory
if tony's have here just as [ __ ] one
is the correct tan i was in case of
glo  ry
both the atomic master and write the
items attitude 17 tot and don't eat it
because
then don't have it marcel storify
bionex anti on hand
plonie items with 17 protons and two
minutes because have atomic mass of tony
's now just with after the next question  the
pop up in her mind is how could i have
an element i do the of opportunities
weapons is 12 tons of ivory glory of
other other elements or something what i am stuck
with this phenomena
led find out more about this mysterious
concept of ice de  jobs in the next video
[Music]